estamos en uno de los centros de
vacunación más grandes del sur de la
florida
aquí se distribuyen más de 700 dosis de
la vacuna cada día desde hace unas
semanas estos centros también están
abiertos a personas no residentes del
estado y también a turistas por eso
muchos de ellos se aprovechan para
viajar expresamente hasta eeuu
especialmente desde américa latina donde
no hay restricciones de viaje para
aprovechar y ponerse la vacuna aquí
muchos de ellos se sienten satisfechos
por cómo está haciendo este sistema de
vacunación ya que sus respectivos países
de américa latina esa distribución está
siendo mucho más lenta si yo vengo desde
mexico para recibir la dosis porque
todavía no han concluido con la
las personas de la tercera edad así es
que aquí es más rápido y tras vacunarse
muchos de estos turistas empiezan a
quitarse la mascarilla y viven una vida
normal y eso tiene un impacto directo en
el sector turístico restaurantes
completamente llenos y hoteles rozando
la plena ocupación aquí nadie se acuerda
de la pandemia
me siento esté más relajado ya una vida
normal ya puedo andar sin mascarilla
ando un poco más protegido lógicamente
también no no se sabía hasta cuándo las
vacunas serán gratuitas para los de
fuera pero se ha visto que esta
inversión está siendo muy buena para
reactivar una parte de la economía